هذه صور مباشره اذا من البوليفارد الذي
يشهد عديد التفاعل فعاليات وتوافد عدد
كبير من همم
السعوديين والزوار كذلك
لمواكبه دخول العام الجديد في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
مراسلنا من هناك يتابع هذه الاجواء عبد
المحسن الحربي مرحبا بك معنا اذا عام سعيد
بعد لحظات نودع العام 2022 ويستقبل العام
الجديد في السعوديه
نعم صهيب بالفعل اقل من دقيقتين والكل
مرتقب هنا وهنا ومحتشد لو نزل الصوره اللي
دقائق قبل بدء العد التنازلي حيث تشاهد
العديد اااه الاف الاشخاص ربما يتواجدون
في هذه المنطقه هنالك منطقتين في هذه همم
في مداخل البوليفارد تتحدث عن المدخل
الاول مدخل الثاني وهي مداخل واسعه تواجد
بها شاشات سيكون هناك عد تنازلي والعاب
ناريه فبالتالي كان هنالك توافق كبير جدا
وكل الاشخاص متواجدين في هذه اللحظات
الانتظار العد التنازلي في لحظات مرتبات
همم الكثير من الاشخاص الحقيقه في عوائل
واطفال وكذلك همم كبار وصغار قدموا
ليحتفلوا
ويودعوا هذه السنه ويستقبل سنه جديده في
هذه المنطقه في منطقه البوليفارد التي
بدات باستقبال زوارها منذ ساعات مبكره
تذاكر نفذت منذ وقت مبكر الكل محتشد هنا
في لحظات مرتقبه لبدء ساعات ال عد
التنازلي كما تشاهد الاصوات ترتفع من حولي
همم
الترقب العد التنازلي
والكذلك بدات عمليه همم تشغيل الاغاني
للاغنيه الرسميه لموسم الرياض وهمم الان
هنالك ايضا همم
الاشخاص او من هنالك احتفالات مختلفه
للاشخاص
وفي جهه اخرى من هناك حيث همم العاب
الناريه في جهه مختلفه في منطقه في همم
بوليفارد وورد كمان نشاهد تفاعل كبير مع
هدير هذه
الفعاليات المختل
والاحتشات لمشاهده الالعاب الناريه في
الرياض
وللاستقبال هذا العام الجديد الكل مبسوط
صهيب ومحتفل في هذا العام
طيب
جديد عبد المحسن اذا دخول العام الجديد في
السعوديه حسب التوقيت اذا توقيت الرياض
دعنا نتابع معك اذا الصور وكذلك الالعاب
الناريه مباشره من البوليفارد في الرياض
[موسيقى]
ايه ده المشاهدين
في هذه اللحظات كمان نتابع معكم جانبا من
الاحتفالات بدخول العام الجديد في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
بالالعاب الناريه وعديد الاحتفالات اذا
دخول العام الجديد
مختلفه هذه الالعاب ناريه ترى من اكثر من
منطقه
عبد المحسن عذرا الصوت والارسال يتقطع من
عندك
لعلنا طبعا نبقى في المتابعه في هذه
اللحظات اذا كذلك
لهذه الاحتفالات اذن بدخول العام الجديد
مباشره من بوليفارد الرياض في العاصمه
السعوديه التي تشهد حركه كثيفه للزوار
للسعوديين كذلك بهذه المناسبه لمتابعه اذا
دخول العام الجديد
والاستمتاع كذلك بهذه الفعاليات وهذه
الاجواء كذلك همم كنت تحدثنا عبد المحسن
قبل قليل عن الجو البارد في العاصمه
السعوديه همم في نهايه 2022 اذن ودخول
2023 اذا كمان نتابع معكم اذا همم استمرار
همم اطلاق الالعاب الناريه وهذه الاجواء
الاحتفاليه بدخول العام الجديد على العموم
اذا السعوديه تودع عام 2022 وتستقبل عاما
تحديدا طبعا عام 2022 كان حافلا
بالانجازات في السعوديه على عده صعد يعني
على الصعيد السياسي على صعيد الاقتصادي
وكذلك وال اجتماعي والتنموي كذلك مع اطلاق
عديده المبادرات والمشاريع ضمن خطط رؤيه
المملكه
وكمان نتابع اذا عبد المحسن اذا كنت
تسمعني الان اذا المتابع معك يعني هذه
الحشود الكبيره الحقيقه في هذه اللحظات
لمتابعه احتفالات الدخول العام الجديد
2023 اذا كنت تسمعني الكلمه لك يا عبد
المحسن
نعم صهيب بالفعل حشود كبيره تواجدت في
بوليفارد رياض سيتي لاستقبال العام الجديد
ومشاهده الالعاب الناريه من مختلف المناطق
في الحقيقه وشاهد جنسيات مختلفه لا نتحدث
فقط عن المواطنين السعوديين والمواطنات
ولكن الزوار بمختلف انحاء العالم حتى
المقيمين تواجد في هذه المنطقه لتوديع سنه
واستقبال هذه السنه الجديده في لحظات صحيح
انها بارده
بملابس دافئه وبمشاعر ايضا دافئه لامنيات
جديده في هذا العام
الجديد همم
لاستقباله والتمنيات همم عام افضل وايضا
خطط افضل سواء كان شخصيه او حتى على مستوى
البلد نتحدث عن السعوديه هنالك انجازات
كبيره حدثت خلال عام 20 22
على المستوى التنموي على المستوى
الاجتماعي على مستوى المشاريع ايضا كان
هنالك على مستوى مشاريع رؤيه 2030
واتحدث عن المشاريع الكبرى من يوم وامل
والبحر الاحمر كان هنالك افتتاحات كبيره
في همم في العام الماضي تحديدا نتحدث عن
اولى المشاريع في رؤيه 2030 وايضا متوقع
في هذا العام ان يكون هنالك افتتاح لعدد
من المشاريع وهي مرتقبه نتحدث عن مشاريع
البحر الاحمر السياحيه واحده من اكبر
المشاريع التي تقوم فيها السعوديه على
مستوى الرؤيا يتوقع ان يتم افتتاحها خلال
هذا العام وهو عام مرتقب عام سيشاهد في
السعوديون
المشاريع الكبرى التي تم الاعلان عنها
والعمل عليها اولى هذه المشاريع ايضا كان
هنالك في عام 20 22 الاعلان عن اكثر
المشاريع طموحا ايضا همم تصميما همم
الم في الحقيقه اتحدث عن همم ذا لاين وهو
مشروع من احداث مشاريع مدينه نيوم همم في
هذه العام الذي تم اغلاقه وبدات فعليا
الاعمال تتم على ارض الواقع في ذا العين
شاهدنا الصور من تلك المنطقه لعمليات
الانشاءات التي بدات فبالتالي هنالك
الكثير من الان لهذا العام
لسعوديين المقيمين وكذا لكل همم همم من
يترقب رؤيه 2030 ومشاريع الكبرى بان تكون
همم هذه المشاريع تبدا باستقبال الناس وهي
انطلاقه جديده للسعوديه همم بافتتاح هذه
المشاريع التي تم الاعلان عنها ويترقبها
الجميع بالاضافه الى عدد من
من القطاعات الاخرى التي تنمو بشكل متسارع
في السعوديه صهيب خلال هذا العام يتم
الترقب لها وبكل تفاؤل طبعا وبي- همم
بتفاؤل كبير من كل قطاعات والناس